over the years we have seen filmmakers
explore the concept of humanoid robots
in more ways than I can list from
Terminator to RoboCop science fiction
has invited us into the possibility of
living with humanoids for some of us
sci-fi is all there is to humanoid
robots so today I will share the 10 most
realistic humanoid robots in the world
let's get into it Amica Amica is so far
the world's most advanced humanoid robot
developed by the UK's engineered art
Amica exhibits the most accurate human
facial expressions to date and fluid
movements of the upper limbs this
humanoid robot can talk using a
microphone and speaker in its chest that
is wirelessly connected to a responding
human on the other side in a crowd Amica
will follow the voice of the person
talking and turn to address them with
the ability to follow a finger with its
eyes I'm sure following a human is a
piece of cake for Amica speaking of its
eyes have cameras that help it process
human facial expressions so it responds
accordingly very considerate just don't
wave your hand too close to the Amica
because it understands personal space
and will brush away weigh a hand that
gets too close though Advanced amaka
can't walk yet unlike the next robot
Sophia Hansen robotics developed Sophia
and she made her public debut in 2016.
Yes you heard right Sophia identifies as
she or her a first for robots maybe we
should call her Sofia the first because
she has had a few firsts for her kind
most notably her citizenship granted by
the Saudi Arabia government and being
named the United Nations development
program's first Innovation Champion
regarding her abilities Sophia's complex
speech system allows her to engage in
conversation and express herself using
over 60 facial expressions I might add
that she can now walk paint and sing
with a decent voice Sophia can also
follow faces maintain eye contact and
recognize individuals this means you
must be nice to her so she returns the
favor when robots take over the world
here's a fun fact about Sophia they
modeled her design after the ancient
Egyptian Queen Nefertiti Hollywood
royalty Audrey Hepburn and inventor
David Hansen's wife Amanda digit from
human faces to no faces at all we move
on to digit by agility robotics digit is
a bipedal humanoid robot with knees that
bend backwards this humanoid can walk on
all kinds of terrain climb stairs and
catch itself from falling over one of
digit's advantages is that it can fold
itself for storage taking up very little
space it is a service robot that can
pick and stack 40 pound boxes which
inspired the partnership between agility
Robotics and Ford this partnership
combines Ford's autonomous vehicle
technology and Agility robotics digit
which may soon see fully automated
parcel delivery straight to your
doorstep so look out for your new
postmate pepper speaking of service
robots over 2 000 companies have already
adopted this next robot pepper is a
SoftBank robotic semi-humanoid robot
that can read human emotions to improve
the quality of interaction with an
advanced understanding of 15 languages
pepper can respond to many people from
different cultural backgrounds Peppa
also has a touch screen attached to its
torso for further interaction unlike the
other robots I just talked about Peppa's
dexterity is not very human-like it's
mounted on Wheels and has 20 degrees of
natural and expressive movements between
its upper Limbs and head pepper is
available to purchase so don't be
alarmed if you find it at your local
restaurant or office building in Japan
some already use pepper as a nanny and
others teach children to code with
pepper Atlas robot now this list would
be incomplete without Boston Dynamics
Atlas robot first unveiled in 2013 when
it started learning to walk the atlas
robot has since seen significant
developments that the team has
documented and shared to show the
progress of the atlas program now it can
walk run jump do a backflip balance on
one leg and even dance at its fastest
Atlas can run at 2.5 meters per second
considering that it was made to Aid
emergency services in search and rescue
operations its speed will come in handy
the team at Boston Dynamics hopes Atlas
will eventually Drive climb ladders put
out fires and perform tasks such as
shutting off valves opening doors and
operating powered equipment in
environments where humans could not
survive looks like the robot age might
just usher in the superhero age Serena 4
moving right along we go to the Serena 4
from the University of Tehran in Iran
Serena 4 is part of the Serena series
developed for over 10 years it is
bipedal with outstanding balance such
that it can balance on one leg and run
at a speed of 0.7 kilometers per hour
Serena 4 is an adult-sized humanoid with
43 locomotive freedom and dexterous
hands that can grip and lift many shapes
and textures its abilities include face
and object detection speech recognition
count position measurement and writing
Serena IV can engage in conversation and
remember your last interaction so here's
another reminder to be kind to robot
kind because they do not forget kaim our
next humanoid is the kind of friend
anyone would be lucky to have and
another first time by macorobotics is
the world's first humanoid bartender
with just the upper body Keim can pour a
drink in 23 seconds with great Precision
so there will be no spills because of
its speed and precision chyme can pour
up to 300 drinks in an hour it can
understand up to 10 different languages
and comes with a built-in kiosk attached
to its upper body complete with a
payment system you might see this robot
serving you at your local Carnival with
room to teach it to serve 10 different
food and beverage items Nadine still
with employable robots our next humanoid
robot is Nadine the social robot
developed by The nanyang Tech University
Nadine was built to be a socially
intelligent humanoid robot Nadine has
soft skin and long hair and could easily
be mistaken for a human at first glance
she exhibits personality mood and
emotions so you can be sure that she
will always let you know how she's
feeling with speech recognition facial
recognition and a great memory Nadine
can also talk back making her a skilled
conversationalist her functionality
includes a wealth of knowledge much like
Siri or Cortana she would make a
brilliant assistant in fact Nadine is a
receptionist her social skills make her
great at welcoming people and engaging
in casual conversation with patrons
Walker X this next robot by upchek The
Walker X stands at 4.75 feet tall and is
self-balancing it is bipedal can walk on
different terrain including stairs and
slopes and uses localization and mapping
technology developed by uptech to avoid
obstacles with 41 motor joints this
robot has great Precision control over
its body it can grab and pass objects
hold up to three kilograms of load per
hand and delicately open a bottle cap
its hand-eye coordination is so precise
that it can pour you a drink without
spilling Walker X's human-like
expressions are from its HD curved
display on its face it has a maximum
walking speed of 3 kilometers per hour
which means it will most likely be the
fastest robot last we saw Walker X was
learning to write and play the piano I'm
so excited to see what else it will be
able to do cyber one to conclude this
list I thought to bring in one of the
latest humanoid robots the Cyber one
from xiaomi this adult size robot like
most on this list is bipedal with its
face in the form of a curved OLED panel
it can see the world in 3D enabling it
to navigate with Precision cyber one can
identify up to 85 types of environmental
sounds and 45 classifications of human
emotion for better human robot
interaction its body has a total of 21
degrees of freedom comprised of 13
joints with each degree of Freedom
capable of responding within 0.5
milliseconds although it has just had
its demonstration cyber 1 has been in
development for a while now so much so
that it has been given the Star Sign Leo
meaning that the engineers who spend
time with it have identified some
behavioral traits that are aligned with
the star sign I don't know much about
star signs but if the demonstration is
anything to go by cyber one just made
Leo my favorite star sign with some of
these humanoids already in service
worldwide it is clear that the Sci-Fi
future is here and soon we may see
broader job prospects for them if you
enjoyed watching this video continue
watching more videos from this channel
by clicking on one of the cards on your
screen see you at the next one